Samuel leaves here and in this video
we're going to be talking about do
height camos work up north so stay tuned
if you are interested in buying hmm up
north or if you have them I'm with my
brother CEO and business partner Russell
Leeds Russell hey dear man I'm doing
very well thank you
you're a HMO King thank you for saying
so well what did you experience in
height remote first my experience HMOs
is something that I've been learning and
investing in for quite a long time also
when I hate to my management company so
we manage hundreds of rooms and you've
bought houses HMOs up north in the
Midlands as both through our business
and personally yeah and you know the
good the bad the ugly the pitfalls the
high returns the lot yeah going to the
work up north no simple answer is yes
but I suppose like anything was gonna be
areas to work the areas that don't work
so it's not you know it's a bit of a
blanket statement what would you say to
people that say I don't want to invest
in a hanger month north because I think
it's too far away from home well what
you always saying which I totally agree
is if you're if you're saying it's too
far away that means you've got a
terrible plan B because plan B means
that you're planning on going and
sorting it out yourself yeah I know what
I say is I say that if your plan if
you're planning on buying it close to
home so that you can step in if there's
a problem that's a terrible plan a
because that means that your plan is to
step in if there's a problem there will
be a problem which means that's not
financial freedom it means that's we
call that a rope around your neck so I
think that the key is to buy in an area
that works and to have a good hmm
manager of course so if up north works
it doesn't really matter where it
doesn't really matter where you live
what kind of areas work really well up
north or working wild you reckon working
weren't off any city's got I think the
rules got off it's gotta be it's gotta
be in areas demand so somewhere like
hull holds good but even anyway even
hole has its parts that work and it's
parts that don't yeah as it's good areas
has its bad areas but hall works we've
we've had some real success we hope
we've had success we've Liverpool
yeah we've had success with Grimsby
Bradford very very much success in the
Midlands in in Birmingham middles or
Midlands is my actual favorite place
yeah but you're in so because you've got
a hmm management company in the Midlands
well maybe but that could be partly true
because you know that you're gonna do
everything to get the rooms wet yeah
because if we do if we have a house or
if we have a house up north we do have
very good power teams and hmm managers
up north but then the best hmm
management in the company has got to be
quick move which is your company yeah
which is the Midlands so what other
things to look for because there are
people who bought North wait doesn't
work
yeah even properties that we've invested
it's not work quite as well I think part
of it is like Stoke got a bit saturate
we'll move on it did it did I think part
of the thing is to really research
before buying because as you say there
are places you can't just look at a
place and go Paul works anywhere in the
whole will work that it doesn't it's not
the case no or Birmingham there no it's
more the case in the bigger cities it's
more likely to work yeah because there's
more demand but I mean if there's lots
of demand in an area but there's also
lots of properties and yours isn't in a
bad area they're all gonna go first yeah
so it's important that you have a good
area I also think you need a good
product so if you don't do the rooms to
the standard that they need to be and if
you're over greedy with the price then
that's gonna mean that you're going to
avoid periods of course so you need to
do you need to have a good product and
the good news is is that there are quite
a lot that darned into a very nice time
people say to me this makes me laugh to
say oh there's more rooms available than
there are people looking for rooms on
spare room
therefore the over the area is
oversaturated and the people that say
that can just absolute morons morons
because think about it think about it if
you are looking to rent a room yeah what
do you do you just don't look who don't
spare room you look at the rooms
available and then you make a phone call
or drop an email view the house put the
deposit down that's what you do like
that's probably what one in 100 people
would do yeah what you don't do is take
your phone do a selfie and create a
profile of yourself saying hey I'm
looking for a room for the record you
have to be a bit weird to do that it's
right yeah totally so if there's more
room but for the saying there's more
products for sale on a bed and there are
people looking but but people don't
create profiles of themselves saying
wanted looking for stuff on eBay
so in this but if you're if you've got a
room to rent out you of course you're
gonna create a profile so this always
always always always always gonna be
more rooms available in spare room than
there are profiles of people looking for
rooms of course you're never gonna buy
you're always gonna think it's
oversaturated well I agree view that I
think you have a good product so I would
say I thought if I was doing it first we
do your research so you gonna want to go
to area you're gonna want to have a look
round make sure it's not you know
horrible horrible looking I was talking
to somebody and they said don't be too
picky just because there's you know cars
on bricks in the road and this sauce it
doesn't mean it won't work
I don't agree just because what they
were like cars on bricks during the
tires and and bad things looking in the
street oh yeah yeah if the streets are
dump but oh I don't agree I think in the
streets a dump avoid it you don't want a
dumpy in my opinion but saying that at
the same time we've got some really
really profitable HMOs and I do think
people generally tend to look in the
street and think would I live here
there's a balance somewhere there is a
balance but we've got HMOs that are you
know in areas which are not great
sometimes I see sofas outside other
people's houses and I'm like oh my
goodness you know if there's broken
glass everywhere in the middle of a red
light I think you've got I think you've
got to use your common sense as well I
think if you go and look at it and it
looks horrible I think that even if you
fill it you potentially gonna be filling
it with people but don't if they don't
mind living if it's terrible
yeah I think of this I think what you
are saying is rather than so because
we're again when people say would I live
there that
silly question because you might only
want to drive a Range Rover does that
mean that Ford Focuses shouldn't exist
yeah of course not No so in the same way
you got to ask yourself instead of
saying would I live in this street would
I live in this room you've got to say if
I was 20 or if I was just finishing
university again my first job or maybe
would I maybe who rather than would I
yeah who would live in if hence there is
like prostitutes and drug dealers then
them yeah but if the answer is oh well
it's not an affluent area it's close to
the city centre you know cuz because
because where I would live wouldn't work
as a HM I know so well it's like what at
the moment because I live in Richmond
city centre but we've just moved we live
in a barn conversion before beautiful
rural affluent but no one would want to
rent a room there it's not near anything
so you got your right you got off the
question who would live here the answer
is absolute scooters then don't maybe
buy there but if the answer is well
working people would live here you know
there because I also do you think this
is important as where you got it you
can't deny this you can't deny that on
spare room when you're looking at rooms
for rent
there usually is not a picture of the
front of the house there is not a
picture of the street there's not a
street view why because people don't
really care
HM oh professional tenants don't care
what the outside of the house looks like
they don't care what the streets the I
would care you would care but you're not
but do your tenants care you know they
don't care
they'd not commit they're not they're
not being hospitable they're just using
this as a roof over their head yeah to
sleep so they don't they're not
entertaining they're not bringing people
back to the house so they don't really
care what the house looks like I don't
really feel it the streets light but
what they do care is if they come out of
the front door in the morning whoever
they get stabbed or not so there's a
limit you know you don't want to be like
oh this area is a bit rough I wouldn't
live here myself
but typically uhm our managers in the
area will I know yeah and be tell you
come as a market research of course it
does
morgan you've got to just find out is
this so so what are the checklist then
so to speak if you if we're buying a hey
chin up north in order to say will it
work
all in the checklist is before but
certainly before I buy something or
before we will let either of our
sourcing companies sell a house to an
investor we always make sure that one
they have spoken to a HankMed manager
who specializes in HMOs who's given them
a like a lowdown of the area what works
what doesn't
yeah - they've spoken to a HMO investor
that could be me if I've got houses in
the area but there's an investor that
says you know gives a lowdown of the
area and what works and what doesn't so
they've got another investor to talk to
yeah and three
they've just tested it they've googled
it they've looked on sparing because
when I said about sparing there's always
gonna be more rooms available than
people looking but at the same time
is anyone looking I always think it's
worth putting up a dummy ad yeah and
I've talked to you about before yeah but
if you if you really serious about going
for an area put you know the dummy ad
and then if someone applies just have a
look at one nearby and so unfortunately
our rooms have gone albums not ready yet
she's going to be honest so they've
rigged up areum's Erin's not ready yet
but here's a room similar yeah I'm just
a little a dummy ads work really well
because if you put a dummy add up and
the phone rings like crazy
I'm just had a guy who bought a house in
Sheffield and he put up a dummy ad
before he completes it and he had nine
phone calls in like three days so I was
I said to him that's gonna work
sometimes you can be surprised
he's just rented it out though he may
need the whole thing out four beds he
bought it for a hundred thousand pound
he made me the whole thing out for
fifteen hundred pound a month in three
weeks sometimes you can be surprised
meet me surprised someone brought us
property in West Brom and we hadn't done
morning West Bromwich before and we were
like Oh
tickly Big Town don't know how she's
gonna work we said look we'll do it we
haven't done West Brom before so I'll
calm speak the areas we'll see how it
goes
whole thing had gone in like three days
I think it was two days and full work
reps no negotiation yes all gone and we
were turning people away left right and
centre yeah it's like wow yeah I never
thought sometimes an area can change as
well you can of course you can buy in an
area like that so
was brilliant and then he got
oversaturated but now it's better than
it was
it's better than it was now so we all
started boiling stoke about three years
ago stop one night immersion stoke and
they'll be behind for like 60 70 grand
and you'd rent them out I thirst why
ever I used to hear everyone going I'm
looking at Stoke I've always known to do
Stoke because they only wanted to do
stuck and that there was hundreds of
investors they're born in Stoke and also
there was this can really change their
cop that lived the market when a big
business comes in mmm this is happening
Grimsby recently mm-hmm and and built a
massive building I think two hundred or
200 odd rooms there's a cinema in there
every rooms all worn sweeted they're
renting them out for 350 makes it hard
to compete yeah unfortunately oh I
bought so cheap like that you know I
bought a couple for like I think it was
like 82 grand you know so I'm not really
gonna moan too much but uh yeah
4-straight a little frustrating but you
need to look at the big picture
you can always within your portfolio
HMOs if you buy three HMOs you probably
gonna have one which just stalls it and
it's just full all the time top rants
and you're like brilliant you're gonna
have one that was okay maybe it's going
to be full eight five nine percent at
the time good tenants it's okay yeah and
and then you're gonna have warm which is
a bit annoying and you've always got one
room that sticks and you know or
sometimes even worse but but overall we
got look at your portfolio as a Hulk
yeah I mean okay people we've sold
properties in Grimsby and you know I
kind of almost I guess I'm pleased but
sometimes people call me and they're
like I rent my whole house that includes
be three weeks thank you so much you it
was your team that you know I'm like
well my rooms aren't full you know so I
you know I think I think it was I think
it was I think it was that big business
that came in and some things but you've
also got a look at comfort appreciation
when people are like when that business
came in although it's a bit annoying
because there's now going to be a
bottleneck for the rooms at the same
time if people if developers are coming
in to an area you know that
he's probably gonna get some capital
appreciation yeah because the is what an
article for comes in when article four
is announced
everybody starts buying in that area and
it can suppose create a bottleneck but
you know that once that article four is
complete and it's in the area you've got
the grandfather rights happen briefly in
Wolverhampton briefly yeah then you're
going to probably is going to go up in
value you're going to have to put your
rents up your competition dead but
you're gonna you're gonna have a
bottleneck so I think I think you've got
to be just realistic I think you've got
to do your market research before buying
making sure that I also think it's
really really good really really
important to have an exit strategy would
the house stack up as a single that yeah
would I be making profit if it was a
single that I think I think the reason
we look come out to the original
question of do hedgerows work in the
north I think the reason they do work so
well in the north
assuming that you take all these boxes
and do it right is just how the north is
just a cheap yeah it's so cheap compared
to the Midlands and then the Midlands is
so cheap compared to the South yeah but
I mean buying a house for like 70 80 90
grand and renting it out for 13 14 15
hundred pounds a month it's just crazy
returns if you if you play your cards
right and do your market research or you
or you or you buy from a sort lot we are
sourcing company they do that they do a
lot I'm not saying they always get it
right but they do they I mean think the
team spend half their time doing market
research yeah you know so if you buy
from a good sorcerer who's done that you
can get a crack in deal not putting very
much money down yeah and getting very
good I think that's another problem I
think some sourcing some people setting
up sourcing companies today and then and
then tomorrow they're sort of saying
I've got all these deals and they're not
deals that man but they sprinkle HMO
fair we just on the property and say
it's gonna be a great you know but
actually they've not done their market
research they've not got an agent in the
area it's gonna be able to rent you out
well and you know and although it yes it
might be a cheap house and yes you might
be able to get a good return it's very
easy to kind of fudge the numbers it is
important to before you buy any house if
you buy it through a sorcerer if you
found it yourself you want to speak to
hmm manager you'll speak to two or three
you want to do your exit strategies and
and also maybe papadum
check spare room do see all their people
and spare incretin profiles if there's
one personal spare room look in and
there's and there's ten hundred rooms
available then okay fine
but don't say there's more rooms
available than there are people looking
as we talked about earlier so what what
are the important things would you need
before buying a house in as a HML north
north specifically yeah or just anywhere
what what would you do import what would
you put in place well what are we
looking at a having a good hmm manager
yeah I've been really important I
definitely was gonna meet them have a
coffee with them try and get a
relationship with them and like you say
maybe speak to a few I think then which
is good important as well you need you
need obviously furniture you need to
decorate it you need to be compliant
yeah well again if you want more info on
that look at the video for another thing
you said which was really good we're
really interested would you said you
love for bed HMOs because you don't need
to get a license yeah and you don't need
just because if you spend a fortune on a
property soundproofing and all that
stuff it's gonna be how have you
returned five beds you're not too keen
on but you're like six pets tell us why
well four beds are great because you
don't have to have a license and you can
save a lot of money on your compliance
side yeah five you need all the crap
that goes with it but you're only in one
extra set of rent out of it but six it's
the same as a five in terms of
compliance to everything but you gain to
it to lots of rent extra rent out of it
than a four yeah and seven that's when
you need to get planning permission but
again if you've already got planning
permission or if you're going to have to
get prime to permission anyway they want
to go the full wall and get a ten bet
yeah great and one of the things we're
working on at the moment we're working
on quite a lot of apartments apartment
blocks yeah service accommodation so
we're gonna do we're going to be talking
about that we've got other videos on
that kind of stuff but um great thank
you very much buddy
no problem at all hope you found that
helpful so there we go do you hate them
as work in the north yes but make sure
you know what you're doing if you
enjoyed that video please do share it
with your fellow investors so they can
be educated and also don't forget to hit
like and subscribe if you haven't
already as well see you next time thank
you so much for watching if you
benefited from that video please do
share it with your family and friends
for more videos like it you can watch
right here
and if you'd like to spend two days with
me at the property investors crash
course watch this video see what happens
but whatever you do don't forget to
subscribe right here and I'll see you
next time